[Music]
for the first time ever we're bringing
together an international Allstar cast
of EX Islanders ready for some healthy
competition and a second chance at
love it's love Island game it's love
Island Game things are going to be very
different this time around I feel the
tension the challenges will determine
everything I'm ready to win this thing
and ultimately witch couple getss
$100,000 winners and I'm a winner I'm
here for love I'm ready to find someone
let's go these games have the CLA coming
out too fac I would say what I would not
want to be called that it's way more
intense than I was expected sneaking
behind my back gives small energy just
so you know tonight I'm probably going
to kiss it again
games things are going to start to get a
lot more strategic it's game time love
Island games is always full of twists
and turns are you me y'all really
brought my ex in who's thinking more
about G who's thinking more about
connection I'd rather be coupled up with
a friend think aing snake what drama
boom hard decisions have to be
made the gles are definitely off it's
time to play this is what you've been
waiting for let's go L what's a
place one more to it